tell me a little bit about your outfit
basically I wanted to wear something
that you think is kind of conservative
and then BAM boom you know I'm saying
like a WoW BAM that's just what happened
to me I looked down and then I was like
oh I don't know if I'm supposed to wake
okay last night cuz it was a 71st
birthday yes yes and you know that
obviously the like famous outfit leotard
she wears with a black course I was like
if cher can do is you 71 dude I'm
putting my ass out on Billboard today
look you gotta own it you know saying
I'm gonna pretend like I did it by
accident all right let me ask you this
yeah that's right how'd that happen yeah
uh what's a secret about this like
something about this outfit that we
don't know I mean well that like there's
no underwear involved and it's just a
straight up like leotard I'm so talking
about but you know what you gotta
sacrifice things passionately are you
looking forward to seeing uh performing
tonight I know you've got exciting
things coming on but what else is Shep
performing tonight she is performing
believe okay that one I wanna do do you
believe in love off the law goes grilled
by Sharon Bushman please don't replay
that no let me just say something there
was no hesitation there which I love
[Music]